Estados Unidos nuevamente enlutado por
otro acto de violencia Armada un hombre
abrió fuego este 6 de mayo en un centro
comercial en un suburbio cercano a
Dallas en Texas las autoridades
informaron que atendieron inmediatamente
al Llamado de emergencia y que el
atacante murió a manos de la policía
uno de nuestros oficiales se respondió a
una llamada en el centro comercial
escuchó disparos entró en la escenas se
enfrentó al sospechoso y lo contuvo
también llamó a las ambulancias las
agencias nos ayudaron a trabajar en la
escena
he hablado con el gobernador quien ha
prometido el apoyo total del estado
los primeros informes aseguran que el
tirador llegó en automóvil al centro
comercial y apenas se bajó ingresó a una
tienda para posteriormente empezar a
disparar indiscriminadamente contra las
personas que se encontraban en el
establecimiento decenas de personas
fueron evacuadas
Mi hija acaba de enviarme un mensaje de
texto y dijo papá te amo y hay una
situación activa ya sabes volátil hay un
tiroteo solo oren por mí así que
corrimos corrimos ahí
las autoridades informaron que se abrió
una investigación para esclarecer los
hechos en lo que va del 2023 Estados
Unidos ha sufrido al menos 198 tiroteos
masivos los cuales son definidos como
aquellos en los que mueren cuatro o más
personas sin incluir al perpetrador
según la organización